[Music]
open for Bliss
okay T is the season for the new
Microsoft ugly sweater and I so hyped
because this one is a throwback it is a
blast to the past this is using the
original photo Bliss that was taken in
1996 off of Highway 12 in somoma County
California in 2001 it became the default
background on Windows XP and there's a
pretty good chance that this became the
most viewed image of all time and now
continuing on it's in the form of a
sweater step one puts sweater on feel
nostalgic upload a selfie we will be
doing all of those
things here it is oh it's beautiful it's
not ugly at
all wow oh it's a nice quality
too oh yeah this looks fresh and here's
the full ugly sweater I'm going to have
to say that I don't think the sweater is
ugly at all I think it's absolutely
beautiful and I will be wearing this
well after the holidays are over